sara is in California hi Sara welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show thank you for
taking my call Dave I really appreciate
it sure what's up I am in a debt free
situation with the exception of my home
mortgage and a home equity line of
credit from my parents
my husband has since lost his job and
between the taxes and my home and the
mortgage it is more than fifty percent
of my net take-home pay I'm about ready
to come into about one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and my question is
should I pay off the loan for my parents
and its entirety and have a little bit
of cushion or should I put that 150
thousand dollars towards my mortgage and
refinance it so it can become more in
line with ratio for from monthly payment
if you refinance er it would that pay
off mom and dad no no I would still have
to owe mom and dad money okay and when's
your husband husband's employment
prospects she's not going to be
unemployed and perpetuation it's been
three years so mom that's a whole
different issue well it's part of the
equation it is it is we're working
through that but what's the balance on
your first mortgage six hundred
eighty-three thousand okay and what is
your take on pay my net is 190 sits
around one for 130 okay doesn't sound
like you can afford this house unless
your husband gets a job in either one of
these scenarios well I've been making
work for three years so it's just very
tight it's absurd it is so you need to
either needs to get a job or you need to
sell the house oh that's really what's
going on I mean 150,000 just doesn't fix
your problem either way
you can't get 683 low enough that it
makes sense on your income it's gonna be
tough I mean you just
it's a tough squeeze so yes I'd pay off
mom and dad and if you want to refinance
and and you probably can get it down a
little bit on a you know we put on a 30
year or something but you're just you're
treating the symptom agreed and you've
got it you know you're gonna have to
deal with this and I don't without you
know you you the two of you are gonna
sit down and say we're either gonna have
to address this or we're gonna have to
move this house
mm-hm and cuz it's just untenable on a
long-term yeah you can pull anything off
for a short period of time and you you
know you've been using baling wire and
and duct tape and holding this thing
together mathematically right it's not
been comfortable oh that's an
understatement
being kind to yourself this is a pain I
mean you're in a real stress scenario
here so yeah I'd pay off mom and dad
because I here's the thing I think
there's going to be an emotional and a
mathematical relief beyond the hundred
and fifty thousand to be rid of having
them looking at your situation through
the lens of money and and you don't have
the payment anymore okay and I think
there's a you know no matter how kind
and sweet they are the borrower is still
slave to the lender and Thanksgiving
dinner tastes different when you owe
your parents money it's you know it's
very difficult for every little raise of
an eyebrow to not be multiplied 100x and
be judgmental in especially when you all
are dealing with some obvious situations
inside your household mm-hmm so yeah I'm
paying off mom and dad that's gonna give
you the best lift and yes if you want to
refinance that's fine but ultimately
don't be in denial ultimately this house
has got to go if he's not going to get
re-employed for some reason or another